hey 42 here if you walk the long and
winding betona trail through the dense
new jersey pine barrens
you'll eventually stumble upon a small
abandoned hamlet
well i say hamlet it's more of a hut
called aung's hat countless random
hikers still show up there every year
entranced and obsessed by the stories
about this place
and searching for a mysterious gateway
to another dimension yes you heard me
right
today nestled amongst a 1.1 million acre
forest
aung's hat is little more than the
abandoned ruins of a shed
but in the 1860s this was a lively
village
with a reputation for bootleg alcohol
and prize fighting
so it was a lovely place to spend your
evenings if you wanted to get punched in
your liver
or poison it ong's hats nomenclature is
just
as much an enigma as its dark and
unsettling history
which don't worry i'm about to tell you
in just a moment
according to local legends the name
comes from an early settler in the pine
barrens
jacob ung ung was a bit of a
a strutting peacock of a man he would go
out of his way to impress the local
ladies with his fabulous clothes
ong's most prized possession was a silk
hat
off displayed proudly on his fopish head
the story goes that a jealous lover took
exception to him being flirtatious at a
local dance one night
so she yanked the glorious hat right off
his
exquisitely cuff your head threw it onto
the floor
and stamped all over it like a spider in
the bath
distressed at seeing his baby abused
aung
threw a paddy then lobbed his hat into a
nearby tree
where it remained lodged in the branches
for many years
and ultimately became a marker for the
village itself
by the late 1980s however ong's hat
had left its best days behind the
descendants of those early settlers had
long since
moved to greener pastures and
all that remained was a single decaying
shed
but this old place hides an
old secret rumors began circulating
after a mysterious photocopied pamphlet
popped up
in various locations all around new
jersey
in the late 80s plastered on the
pamphlet was a title that seized the
attention of local residents
ong's hat gateway to the dimensions
it was supposedly published by the
institute of chaos studies
and moorish science ashram and opened
with a sentence that would make any
conspiracy buff go weak at the knees
you would not be reading this article if
you had not already penetrated
halfway to the institute of chaos
studies you have been searching for
us without knowing it wow whose
curiosity wouldn't be peaked by that
mine is and i already know it's probably
a load of bollocks
according to the pamphlets the pine
barrens were home to the moorish science
ashram
a commune set up in 1978
by seeker of spiritual enlightenment and
international carpet salesman
wally fard he'd been traveling all
around the east
india persia afghanistan dipping his
toes into all sorts of spiritual
practices
from indian tantric to the islamic
practice
of sufism doing his very best to flug a
few turkish rugs along the way
and he must have been a pretty good
salesman because when he returned to
america
he'd made enough money to purchase 200
acres of land in the pine barrens it was
here
he founded the aforementioned moorish
science ashram
where fard and his converts would spend
their days
indulging in all kinds of bizarre
pseudo-scientific nonsense
apparently the spiritual rhythms in the
place were ideal for that kind of thing
and spiritual rhythms are something you
should always ask your estate agent
about when by england
whilst the inhabitants of the ashram
were trying to
unravel the mysteries of the universe by
jumping up and down cross-legged on a
mattress
it just so happened a couple of real
scientists
twins frank and althea dobbs showed up
in nearby aung's hat
well i say real scientists
frank and alfie had been kicked out of
princeton university
under charges of seditious nonsense
i should not for experimenting in
chaos studies so they took their chaotic
curiosities into their own hands
by building a secret lab at ung's hat
before long fard and the dubs twins
combined their nut job research
programmes
morris science ashram and the institute
of chaos studies respectively
and began working together mixing their
knowledge of things like classical
physics
meditation quantum mechanics and alchemy
into one big stew of insanity
after a few months and after their
membership numbers had swelled
significantly
they had garnered enough knowledge and
followers
to build a mysterious device called
the egg yeah it was roughly the size of
a small car
and was described as a modified sensory
deprivation chamber
it had a computer terminal electrodes
which could be taped to the body to
collect
data and a helmet which could sonically
stimulate brain cells
the original purpose of the egg
was for the researcher to be shrunk to
atomic
size and descend to the quantum level
like sci-fi micro naughts as the
pamphlets described
with the goal of discovering the point
at which a wave becomes a particle
known as the collapse of the wave
function in quantum physics
and thus solve schrodinger's famously
unsolvable dead cat in box
but the first time the egg was fired up
something unexpected happened it didn't
shrink
because you know that would be totally
expected and
normal but it disappeared
into thin air and then as the pamphlet
so eloquently puts it
for about seven minutes the entire ics
lost its collective cool at that point
however
the egg reappeared with its passenger
intact
and beaming like alice's cheshire cat
rather than schrodinger's poor victim
the man
explained he traveled to an alternate
dimension
in a forest very much like the pine
barrens
everything was exactly the same the
earth was lush with nature
but with one crucial difference in this
dimension
human life had never developed
he was alone after this discovery
things started to go really wrong for
the ashram and ics
there was a nuclear accident at a nearby
military base which threatens the
residents with radiation poisoning
and government agents carried out a
violent raid on the compound
in order to destroy the egg things were
all getting a little
too chaotic for them and this is a group
that called itself
the institute of chaos studies i mean
sure they were doing their best to rip
apart the fabric of space and time
but was a bit of peace and quiet too
much to ask
faced with the possibility of more
inconsiderate interruptions
they unanimously decided it was time to
emigrate
not to another forest but another world
remember they had just conveniently
created a device
the egg that traveled through a gateway
to another dimension
so sure enough they transported
everything to this other world trailers
huts laboratories you name it
leaving behind only a small building to
obscure
the gateway from praying guys and
presumably
they're still up to building egg-shaped
tardises and other weird
in this alternative dimension to this
day
and all we have now is their story
fully divulged in the aforementioned
pamphlet
the pamphlet also reveals that these
universe hoppers
still travel back to our world every now
and then
to pick up vital supplies specifically
books
computers and coffee now
books and computers fair enough but you
must have a pretty extreme caffeine
addiction if you're willing to travel
between
universes just to pick up a jar of nest
cafe
no unfortunately i have a rather large
confession to make
no not that and this may come as
somewhat of a shock if you're mental
all of what i just told you is
completely
made up aung's heart is a real place
and there is an abandoned hut there but
the rest of the story
secret science camps in the forest eggs
and a gateway to another dimension
that's all fake i know it all seems so
utterly believable but bear with me i'm
not just telling
made-up campfire stories for the sake of
it
well perhaps a little the fictional
story of what happened at ung's hat
is unlike other fables because
it has a really interesting backstory of
its own
you see the story of aung's hat just so
happens
to be the internet's very first viral
hoax the story of aung's hat and
the egg was first published in 1988 in a
magazine called edge detector
it was credited to writer peter wilson a
friend of one
joseph muffini who would later turn out
to be the story's primary creator
mafini is a writer from chicago who is
fascinated by
alternate reality games and aung's hat
was his masterpiece thought to be
the first alternate reality game that
spread via the early internet
and captivated the minds of millions if
you're unsure what an alternate reality
game is
you may have heard of a creepypasta
which is essentially the same thing
a creepy often paranormal story
copied and pasted around the internet
and elsewhere
and modified by random individuals along
the way
who add to and expand on its backstory
so much so that it can reach the point
where it's difficult to differentiate if
the story did actually take place in the
real world or not
particularly as they often blend facts
with fiction
so in 1989 mufini and friends
were leaving photocopies of the un's hat
pamphlet in places like
coffee shops magazine racks in stores
along the pine barrens hiking trails
and anywhere else curious minds
dissatisfied with their real lives
might stumble across it soon enough they
were offering the brochure through mail
order
and advertising it in places like ufo
newsletters
and paranormal magazines and then in
1990 it was published at a popular book
catalogue
called incunabula a collection of
descriptions of books and papers
on alternative worlds and alternative
science
mafini's idea was to get the story of
aung's hat published in his many
different publications and locations as
possible
to give the story he'd made up veracity
so if any intrepid conspiracist
went down the rabbit hole of research he
would find a slew of source material and
references
and it worked to a certain extent
by the mid to late 90s the mystery of
aung's hat and
the egg had piqued the interest of
countless travelers
and conspiracists but just when it seems
the story of aung's hat
had spread as far as 20th century
technology would allow
something called the internet came along
and miffini suddenly realized
this new technology could transform his
story
from local curiosity to global
conspiracy
so he started posting the ung's hat
story on every primitive web page he
could find
bulletin boards forums anything was fair
game
it spread fast and aung's hat obsessives
started referring to themselves as
eggheads
filling forums and blogs with their own
theories and findings
and by the late 90s early 2000s
people started to believe that just
reading about aung's hat
was doing weird things to them strange
dreams were reported
along with unusual visual perceptions to
be fair i've had the very same side
effects after visiting that weird corner
of youtube
you know the one mafini always claims
the entire aung's hat thing was carried
out in good fun
and to be fair there were interviews
available
at the time where he clearly described
it as a game
in fact a photo of the aung's hat
survivors in one of their many brochures
and pamphlets
is quite clearly a photo of american
sitcom family
the brady bunch it soon became obvious
however
that half of the so-called eggheads were
failing to
bite the bread crumbs mafini was leaving
behind
they were so invested in ung's hat
mythology
they refused to reconcile the reality
in 1999 muffini published his book
ong's hat the beginning then he spoke
about aung's hat on a popular paranormal
radio show
coast to coast am and from here
things started to get weird well more
weird
even though miffini had left many clues
behind
even in the original pamphlet that the
uns hat story
was made up just a game eggheads
all around the world started taking it
far too seriously and were demanding
answers from him
conspiracy theorists ufo obsessives
and the genuinely mentally ill were
hounding
mafini for more information they sent
him threatening emails
phone calls letters and then
they started showing up at his house by
the year 2000
mafini was finding conspiracy theorists
camped out on his lawn
he was forced to march one intruder off
his property at gunpoint
one of these cracked eggheads even
contacted muffini's employers
claiming he was a dangerous liability
which is a bit rich coming from people
who genuinely believe in a new jersey
vortex
and so in 2001 he finally came clean
he posted an open letter online to the
effect that he no longer wanted anything
to do with the whole
aung's hat thing and concluded by saying
i am glad to finally be myself again
it was signed the real joe mafini
but you can't keep a good tinfoil hat
owner down for long
and the conspiracy theorists weren't
about to be satisfied by something as
flimsy as the creator of the hoax
coming out and saying the hoax
is definitely a hoax so conspiracy
theories
about the conspiracy theory started to
spread had the government got to miffini
had they threatened him had someone
bought his silence
mafini's confession ultimately brought
the harassment from strangers to an
end well mostly but he still couldn't
seem to help himself
he clearly enjoyed playing with the
egghead's paranoia
giving vague answers to their questions
and
constantly keeping them guessing in 2001
he even worked as a consultant
on an entirely new internet hoax based
around the character
of john teeter a time traveler from 2036
who made worrying predictions about
nuclear war and other catastrophic
events
which turned out to be the creation of
florida lawyer larry haber
ultimately the story of aung's hat may
not be real
but its legacy is some say it's the
first alternate reality game in history
at least the first that went viral and
there are still plenty of people out
there today
desperate to believe in the mythical egg
and the presence of an interdimensional
vortex somewhere around the ominous
hut at aung's hat there are plenty of
youtube videos of people hiking around
the new jersey pine barrens
searching for wrong's hat desperately
hoping to uncover
a gateway to another world and go for a
ride in the egg
and here are we to crush their hopes and
dreams
even if they are mental after all in
this day and age where the internet is
consumed by yet more args
vr headsets and video games that
enable you to shout violent profanity at
people from all over the world
the line between fiction and reality
is blurrier than ever before thanks for
watching
you can get your hands on my book stick
a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you